hello to you gideon you brought the
complaint that led
to the equality and human rights
commission report are you satisfied with
its findings
very much so this is a report which ends
the debate
it makes very clear that the jewish
community was right
all along we are completely vindicated
whenever everybody said that this was
exaggerated that this was a smear
campaign as jeremy corbyn is still doing
they were wrong and not only were they
wrong they were essentially saying that
jews are liars they were saying that
when we allege anti-semitism we do it
for some kind of political means as part
of some kind of agenda
and that's anti-semitic too and it's not
it didn't take very long after jeremy
corbyn
made his statement this morning for him
to be suspended we
sent our complaint in and minutes later
within the hour we had confirmation that
jeremy corbyn had been suspended
the whip removed and that he was now
subject to
a disciplinary investigation and
this really takes us full circle because
the reason that we referred the labour
party to the equality and human rights
commission in the first place
is that we were making complaints
against jeremy corbyn which for
political reasons due to interference
within the party
were not being investigated and all that
british jews have asked
all along is that british justice be
allowed to
serve its course and today the equality
and human rights commission
issued its report and that as far as
we're concerned
is the beginning of the dispensing of
british justice
jeremy corbyn meanwhile though says he
will contest
the decision to suspend him and remove
the whip and describes it as political
intervention i wonder what you make of
that
the this is what jeremy corbyn has been
saying all along he's been saying it
since 2015 when we first started to
raise concerns about jeremy corbyn back
then
we were vilified there were very few
people who
really understood that anti-semitism
exists on the left as well as the right
and over the years under jeremy corbyn's
leadership
according to our research with yukov and
king's college london anti-semitism on
the far left actually overtook
anti-semitism on the far right so jeremy
corbyn has been making these arguments
for years and the difference now
is that he is a back bencher
a crank who is well
lost uh in the debate he who
has fully lost the debate he is somebody
who
will not see what is real he will not
see that he
presided over a political party which
led to
47 of british jews questioning whether
they had a future in this country and if
you just let that sink in that's the
labour party that created
the equality and human rights commission
then becoming the party
that caused nearly half of an entire
minority community
to question whether they still had a
future in this country
kirsten said today that it was a day of
shame
but that the party will now repair the
grief how does it go about doing that
well the equality and human rights
commission has really spelled out
a very comprehensive set of
recommendations that the labour party
must now
adhere to the labour party has been
given until december
to come up with an action plan that
action plan will have to be agreed with
the equality and human rights commission
and it will actually be enforceable in
court
so this is a uh the road
uh the labour party must travel we have
also made a complaint today
against jeremy corbyn and various other
sitting mps
who were immune from disciplinary
proceedings whilst jeremy corbyn
was leader of the party secure has been
given six months by us
to ensure that those disciplinary
complaints are heard
under the new independent disciplinary
proceedings that the equality and human
rights commission has mandated so
secure has an awful lot of reform to do
but as we see today with the suspension
of jeremy corbyn it's really
he's proving that he can take the labour
party and turn the corner
he has a big fight on his hands as we've
seen people like john mcdonnell
and various other mps who are still
serving labour mps
coming out in force to defend jeremy
corbyn
and really give to amplify his lie
that the jewish community exaggerated
and overstated things for political
purposes those people need to be dealt
with as well
and zakir is going to have a fight on
his hands but we are his ally in that
fight
everybody in the jewish community is
willing him to succeed
and hoping for the day to return when
jews feel safe
within the labour party